oh I talk to you every night I care
products last week I put up a YouTube
video of me becoming financially free
all over again in seven days flat it got
quite a lot of media attention and a
heck of a lot of questions and comments
so this is part two where I answer all
of the comments and show you some of the
figures and deals that are secured in
your [ __ ] part we just left this
family strip from always smells I am
important are much the diving this wild
adventure what are we doing let's get
down to business
I'll be stripping everything so I'm
stuck all over again from scratch I've
been dumped into a sink you made really
hard for some I probably in the back
then I need to start building my
property portfolio again from scratch
with nothing let's see what happened
within two weeks I've never seen
anything like this before and
documenting everything this is the
financial freedom challenge hey I am in
Sheffield as Samuel Leeds and I'm just
gonna go and go around the apartment
start secured and I'm going to show you
around and give you some details of the
figures and hey company hey baby I can't
find it so I'm actually just here I'm at
the penthouse look around it's fabulous
we've got bookies committing like crazy
and I thought I'd answer some questions
the people asked on the group around the
figures and some of the detail and what
happened
so I'm also
friends and so the success to our step
coming up hey what do you think of the
apartment bro is stomach is nothing now
two apartments you've seen with a five
people yeah coming just today to rent
the property and they move out while in
the big rooms and it's do you know is
immaculate
with any condition really good they're
well they're created and well-dressed is
when I believe our founders so quick
now should we go through some of the
questions because you also understand
combination wrenches and all kinds of
stuff so you maybe can chip in so let's
have a little look and see what some of
these questions are all the money all
the inclination all the time you can do
it without the money we kind of going
for you in which my case it was the
knowledge those questions are there
coins done so someone said Tony garage
Dale said did you pre-warm the letting
agent that you intended to use the
property as a renter and before you
meant to have the property yes
absolutely a little newbie but I always
say upfront you know this is how I'm
going to be doing it I'm going to be
renting out corporate and I've actually
got the contract I've got the corporate
letter breathin in my car as well keep
safe and being stored some of us about
the same I think the biggest thing for
me is system systems from service
departments his systems this is my first
common property since it's been live
or cleaner as Congress said you need to
clean up you need to have good systems
like people in the building and I
friends we just rocked off we are here
today on today but we just rolled up
we've got pieces out things that are Tom
yeah we've been using but I've been
using the company called T next so keep
this for a company where it's like
boomer with uber but they lock keys off
and you can pick them up and it's it's
ok but the worst thing is when you
physically have to go and let them in
everyone who's going to see I said I
have to go to understand museums click
keys yeah absolutely the best system is
to just have a key safe and we literally
just today 15-pound from all of us and
we're gonna pull the keys out there but
up until now I've been using key next so
basically you're the dealer got the keys
I was so excited I just put it on Bobby
calm and and me and Ben stuff really
fast in a bit of a rush start getting
bogeys comin another one yeah you know
God
Kulik Lena she said yeah we've got that
worked out I was really excited and then
I was so excited I just booked a
spontaneous vacation to Dubai spend two
weeks in Dubai which I had to kind of
keep a little bit on the low because I
didn't want everybody to know us and
goodbye
because they ruin the finale of the
challenge so we even had one of so many
bookings are so excited because it's
December time December's what a crazy
good month for service de combination
but could not could not gain access they
clean up here it was just terrible so
what I'm in Dubai I mean you probably
see the video out in the beach getting
bookings great actually I spent about
three hours on the phone like
so I think systems are just so worn
systems good people and then of course
Samuel Leeds can use his power team that
Lukas worthy ask him to get one Network
get my system start from scratch
normally Samuel leads or get a property
deal or with the entrepreneur but then
as soon as I found it it's cured the
deal I'll just go over to my team so
saying that the systems from scratch
it's very doable but it was it was
really tricky some of the questions I
get has the laws is how you go get
finally cleaners just do Google if you
know people that accommodation probably
that's them yeah because you you don't
just need someone to clean just turn the
lights off if the Indians you know get
to submit the lights on what look at the
online management system of the calendar
and be able to be aware when they go in
when they go out there really to just
own it and that way it really is
completely passive yeah I hope it has
been interesting so far but Lucas please
walk us through your cold cool pitch to
the letting gadget pretty simple I just
found the van engine and I'll just say
hi I've seen that you've got a couple of
apartments on but I'm still available
yes they are fantastic and one anxiety
prove it leads and I'm actually I have a
corporate lack green ups yeah so don't
know if the landlord will be open to a
guaranteed rent let's say a three to
five year period it can certainly ask
that question great and we do that for
corporate let's odd moving my guests are
be easy that was probably the most
terribly worried but it's okay
okay it's not about being mr. smooth
yeah do not go in and see if you're
gonna rent to yourself and then go
actually buy whatever just be like I'm
ogling bumbling idiot
but just put all my cards on the table
you know what do you mean I'll just take
it off before I'm booking calm air B&B
but it's nice to be up front from the
bathroom
leave off safe because if you build any
relationship or mistrust yeah it's not
thank you if ya if you just tell
everything up front and they're like oh
no you've lost 30 seconds of your life
there's a million other agents to phone
but if you ring up and just totally
honest bit of a bumbling bumbling idiot
but ten exactly when you claim you're
doing it there okay that sometimes
they'll say oh yeah we've done that
before like this particular agent she
was reasonably familiar with it she's aa
booking.com yeah so you brick you get
you remove the right agent is it
property businesses are people business
it's not about the properties about him
with the drug people and then the videos
will come the thing I'll say about
service accommodation is it's some
months will be better than others so
someone's will do really well like
January is the quietest month so right
now I can look it up looking at what's
going on but but you need to look at it
over a 12-month period so when people
said to me once
anything on the service on these two
apartments I don't know exactly the
rough figures you've seen everything
yeah yeah and you're quite pleased mr.
conservative so renting them out for
between a hundred 100 is the mid me mom
but for between a hundred and then right
up to believe it like 300 or nine for
this one this is a big muscle penthouse
it's got four bedrooms so you know on
average I'd say probably about 150 pound
per night per apartment
one of them's a two-bed apartment this
was a four-bit penthouse I'm looking out
I can see a balcony in all the views
right now if we do it up tall joy so
even with
I think Sheffield the average occupancy
rate is around about 80% so 90%
occupancy right with those kind of
figures you've got a lot of big pie
to play with and cut up with on paying
the landlord six hundred and fifty
pounds per month for the to bat and then
I'm paying 1250 per month for this
penthouse so my expected profit is going
to be a roundabout thousand pounds for
the downstairs for the downstairs for
this one
so whatever it takes because hero zero
zero zero in profits happy yeah twelve
hundred pounds to get insurance to get
registered with an ombudsman or a
redress scheme yeah you talk about 12 it
depends which one paid for within half a
deal you know so hope that makes sense
okay Carl Harrison and it's a good
question if you were to continue beyond
the one-way would you
the strategy you'd start it or consider
other options well yeah probably carry
on doing that's what research did you do
in calculating potential revenue for
serviced accommodation apartments really
good question you know what a lot of
people I see so many motivated idiots do
serviced accommodation and they get
sober marry you can get the wrong timing
you can not do them the galaxy checks
you cannot you cannot get systems in
place there's so much to go wrong
wherever there's higher reward I a very
little money down thousands of pounds a
month pink there's always there's always
a flip side and we've service the
combination of flip side is making sure
that you have the rook you need to be
pretty down so even me doing the
challenge I've got a bit stuck in a bit
stopped because I'm so used to my team
doing it even though I'll die and I know
it so you know how do I know the area
you can you can check you can you can
check on like air B&B on air B&B you can
see the average occupancy rate of hotels
you can actually check by looking into
trying to book hotels and seeing how
busy they are you can also speak to
other investors them do we get the way I
do it is very similar so you can go on
to all these sites picking up call me
baby you can take other people's puppies
here or pad there are you can pick on
the next month or next week see how busy
things are because really good
explanation on how much people getting
her a room a night speak to lots of
service accommodation agents the risk
lords like in check with a sports agent
which will manage FC Porto's not even
the best area but I was desperate it was
desperate to know the lady behavior but
the thing is
but she's my friend
yeah and if you refuse track it down you
know she'll say she'll say happy those
families is training on service to
commendation why are you an Academy
member and if you be interested because
it's not good for anyone because if you
take on a property for service
accommodation but mule you do know when
you're doing what's gonna happen is it's
not gonna make a profit so you're a
loser and then the agent or the landlord
is not you're not going to pay their
rent and then they're going to be really
annoyed I mean you're a loser
it's giving us a bad name and you're
gonna you're gonna you know get
permission from the mortgage company
you're not going to check the lease and
you're not gonna be able to get commits
correct permission with the lease it's
just gonna be do you know our callin
program I hear about people that are
normally well educated about Benjamin
they going to get apartment love Anna is
walking and then the landlord comes in
and says I do that because they're quick
question okay Adam Smith I don't Smith's
always commenting things like this and
to be honest yeah why didn't you use a
person with no property knowledge at all
maybe I should have used him maybe next
time well the reason I did it was
because it would have been a real boy
documentary because we just feel into
life it would be pretty boring so that's
why I did it we made
you want to be that and what did you
just go and film at you can do that yeah
yeah
my mother would watch the documentary
and he's soon you went through some
training yeah yeah yeah I did
realistically how much education does it
take for one to get to the level of
proficiency you just buy it in those
seven days it was a real touch and it
was a real touching at one point here
he's of the opinion and we'll knew he
could not get those results especially
when convincing people to deal with you
first don't matter
yeah I expect 10 years getting the
experience and I'd spend about three
quarters of a million getting trained
yeah yeah so twelve months and it's been
twelve run with me I'm in the club every
week embedded everyone with other people
yeah okay so how much maybe if you want
to get to his piece off on a better one
on like on making millions be making 30
grand a month
yeah and you spent 12 rounds it
certainly proved me but yeah of course
you need training
of course it if you took a brand new
beer with no money and filmed it for a
week wasn't the whole point of the task
was something with the knowledge yes
start again from zero with nothing again
someone just said do you think you would
have successfully completed the
challenge if you'd have had no property
knowledge or experience I think some
people just missed the point
yeah okay understand go he said yeah
honest that Konig um I don't even see
that
Colet they go he said this is a great
idea I can't wait for this oh it was
nice it felt like for this on these fees
in it so anyway I'd love some details on
how you build your list for deal
sourcing and converted the deals into
sales
okay well ready for that I just
literally went down to anything I could
go to I was searching on Google verse
late for business networking events
property narrowing events BNI there's
four and that's Bob clubbers business
networking groups that call then there's
property networking groups I can for
instance property investors network
given the property investors circle a
property meet property home there are
these things that do exist so what I did
was I just went online I found well I
knew there was going to be people so so
tell what I do or gaming and then I look
up leave the conversation on hi come
back to in a bit
not not do you yes do you know it's you
know what hardly sounds good and you
know who do you know
so might be just doing myself cool well
drop me the details oh my email sure
I've got his details that's one more
person and then I'm just going around
building my list like that I went to one
networking event I left I left with 27
details of people and I rectum or
so that's how I did it and also some of
the dealers I sold I've sold them but I
know people that I met with that money
interests they have passed me to
somebody else and I was just like a
maverick on the phone you think it's
right building building list I do this
regular I ever step by step system for
doing this but most people network wrong
so was that how did you handle estate
agents questions when setting up the
rectum NSA varmints I didn't handle
automatically be honest
yeah it's time I can be terrific did you
have to secure the deals without having
to show proof of funds cool yeah so the
estate but the estate agent said to me
and I can put forward your offer but
first I need to see your proven phones
and I said what are they going to accept
my offer because I'm a busy man
and I don't really want to like send you
my solicitors and well this if they're
just gonna turn on as I know and they
sure oh no no I mean yeah and then she
quickly changed into you and then she
came back and said yeah them accepted
your offer cannot these any documents
then are no problem I'll get them as
soon as I can for you should send them
tomorrow Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy took our
email the details that outsold the deal
and I said to him look at your documents
he said yes I then got them off him
forwarded them to the agent hook the two
together and took my fee in the mirror
oh let's see if I'm easy done no problem
so thank you for the question out any
clean how did you work that your
sourcing fee of two and a half thousand
pounds
supply dinner yeah you know there's no
magic some people say some people try to
pretend that there's someone magic know
that it's just a case of visual appeal
if you know that the deal is you'd be
really popular you get over say like
that from queueing up you just charge
what you think
because you don't decide you decide they
decide how much they're going to back so
units just then how much it's going to
gauge your body comes of experience but
the average sourcing fee will sell
between about two and five grand this
question I get all the time actually
what are the main legalities of setting
up service accommodation you know what I
can even build a long long video if I go
into that so may things lease and at
least the mortgage permission from the
landlord contracts if you are not able
to dedicate the time you've had and
we're working a job like eight to six
during the challenge how would you do it
then I would have just taken a week off
work yeah I know chief financial point
at least seven days yeah you might have
to work eight hours a day
or nine hours for ten hours a day Monday
through Friday but you've still got a
lot of time left so maybe it would take
you maybe maybe eighty three weeks
what's typical we got whatever right
you can either find excuses or well I
think the challenge would have been a
bigger challenge if it's been done in a
different market marketplace one that
you didn't already have the knowledge in
yeah maybe but properties one on that so
maybe they would have found where you're
most nervous on day one or day six oh
good question
belladonna nervous on day minus one the
day before
I would shake it but actually going out
and I actually remember speaking to you
that the air peoples must be defending
parts of the Fe and that's when you
pulled an email Pat yeah and you will
literally leave in the DfE that might go
yeah and I know then you are mid nerve
and so on so I pulled them up or the
place by the way this this was a random
say like to the point we had a facebook
life the guys did it not like that they
put the different things in a hat they
were trying to stitch me up Trevor to
Scotland in there and that same ribbing
evening by using corporal that I just a
corporal that contract and believe it or
not the ancient people who can asking me
about what deals are sold and stuff and
how about 8,000 pound I don't think in
the documentary super clear okay so I
sold three deals I know that one I just
found those the leaves there to or many
of you go to properties we couldn't
follow the story of each property which
was disappointing I might write a book
or something on exactly what happened so
you get the [ __ ] the fourth story but I
start with three properties hate Jamar
we developed opportunity and a red to
essay and then with that learning I had
a look deuce to get these two properties
okay
which is walked out like when doing the
takedown and that was just deposit from
a little small application big a little
bit about and they just thought as I'm
doing anyway that's why I gave the money
to charity and also I bought them the
mechanic who saved me a car broke down
became we fix the cars and how much do I
owe you another thing and he looks at me
and he looked at the car anyway I was
like thank you so much
so the end of the week who are called
his box I called the office and I
supposed to speak to the boss and I said
to him you know the colaprico car Tony I
want to leave a good review on your side
and really happy I said kind of get to
the gift
yeah you can bring him in a bit a bottle
of beer or something I said not to
especially yeah well I see this photo
broken and the amount of money it would
cost to get me a new phone I just have
left over anyway thanks man how did you
sell the deals to investors of the
property event I didn't I didn't sell
them at the event I saw them after them
at the event the purpose was to just
build my lips gain trust put myself on
the map and then after when I'm away I
really love this make Michelle man whoo
basically yeah like a breakdown of the
rent to sa that looks like I don't know
you got that from another like very much
bang on so this is just a breakdown of
her predictions of how much I've been
making for the right to her side which
works out to be like two thousand six
hundred which is very very close now as
I said before until you look at it in an
over 12-month period
you don't know for sure it's early
predictions but some say Robert Gregory
what on how did he work on his mindset
when starting out to get belief and
focus dude I've spent 10 years investing
in myself and personal development on my
focused on a person but yeah it was
tough it was it was nerve-wracking but
I'm not afraid to just step out and look
stupid so join Russia look around yeah
around but maybe the guests are do what
one of the guests do I think what we've
shown you around the guest mark on we
might hang around
all I'm just just so you can meet the
guests if they'll be able camera yeah to
persuade them but we've got a full house
a full house and we've got a lot of
things it so it's a real success overall
and I just want to massive thank you
guys for supporting me the challenge
between spire people and over people's
mind set up and change their perspective
then then that was a little bit too
intimate I think any profits that I make
from from these properties I've got no
chance so this is the like a lounge kind
of area of the penthouse which is
beautiful balcony right here so no it's
gorgeous
anyway I won't show you every single
bedroom but you can get the gist this is
what all the bedrooms I look like
beautiful I said I wouldn't show you
every bedroom maybe oh well Samuel
drilling a hole go and give it some
welly God we're creating some sticky
labels to put on the Keisei so that they
know which ones which I don't think I
guess
[ __ ] that
hey you alright alastair is the cleaner
and also he's also actually documenting
everything so I hope you don't want him
following me around with our we're gonna
we have interests of these turrets from
North Wales so when you put it in and
then mix the coder okay is that cool
yeah awesome right
you know what property investing is in
business these guys here they're my
customers this house is my product
they'll never forget that's what not
it's easy to think no you want to have
value
I've helped develop you be guaranteed
rent I'll make given these guys a lovely
evening and there's also a lot of people
asking like what kind of contracts are
used so I'll show you exactly what I
used this is a company that Tennessee
agreement company Ruby's place and Lucas
penthouses baby and the reason I've done
that we've got different key codes
because otherwise they might
accidentally stay in the penthouse
so they'll you know they'll get emailed
when they book on the code when the
cleaners come in they can just change it
every so often every time different
investors that some people get really
hung up but here's my sales pitch if you
would like to come and stay here I'd
recommend a Lucas penthouse or Ruby
apartment on about a link below so you
can come and stay in my serviced
accommodation to actually see firsthand
exactly what it's like what the setup is
you may even meet the cleaner and it
would also mean I'll get more bookings
so win-win right now come and stay I'd
love to your have you with my guests
the cleaner but likes to call himself
[Music]
[Music]
know if you could actually leave if you
just put this back so you're in
rooby-roo his place so he could just put
it back awesome so we've got a whole
bunch of 6/6 happy guests for the night
and now it's all set up so it's going to
be systemized and passive again love the
apartment so good ever done well they're
very well done' better following them
yeah yeah good money good apartment
phenomenal all that money's meeting as
charity as well all the profits so very
good peace out CX time see you guys